so what's all this talk about this this
liver thing is is it that important do
we really need a liver
yes you need a healthy liver and the
problem is the majority of population
has a fatty liver and a lot of people
don't even know that they have fat in
the liver until they get an ultrasound
or they get a cat scan and then they're
they're shocked so i think it's number
one important understand
about the liver and the importances as
well as how to get the fat out of the
liver there's a great simple thing that
you can do which i'm going to talk about
and there's also a drink that you can
make every day
to reduce fat on your liver and with
some pretty good science behind it and
i'm going to put those links down below
with each of the ingredient that i'm
going to talk about the first thing i
want to mention
about the liver is that
people don't realize that
bile is made by the liver they think
it's made by the gallbladder no the
gallbladder is just a sac that holds the
bile
but i want to talk about the importance
of bile for a second because the liver
makes the bile and the more you
understand about what bile does you'll
appreciate the liver much much more now
bile is a detergent that helps you break
down fat
but exactly what does that mean break
down fat let's say for example this is
some fat okay
and this is traveling through the
stomach you just ate some fat and it's
going to be now going down into the
small intestine so the stomach will kind
of break it down to a certain level but
then we need help from the gallbladder
releasing bile to act on this
this big clump of fat right
so the problem is that um
bile needs help to break this thing down
and it uses help from the pancreas
there's an enzyme
and the pancreas called lip base okay
lipid meaning fat
ace meaning enzyme the problem is that
in order for lipase to do its job it
needs
the bile's help and what the bile is
going to do it's going to break down
this
significantly so there's more surface
area for the enzyme to act on so this is
what bile does so the file starts to
break this down into small little pieces
here
so let me just kind of break all that
down right here all right so now we have
a much greater
surface area
of
fat
for
the enzyme lipase to do its job okay so
simply bile increases the surface area
of fat
so you can get more of a complete
digestion of that fat in the extraction
into the small intestine that's where it
gets absorbed
so without enough bile
then the enzyme can't do its job and now
you don't get enough vitamin a the first
symptom of a vitamin a deficiency is
like night blindness so you're
you're driving at night it's raining and
you just can't quite see it's hard to
see at night okay night vision that's
vitamin a i mean vitamin a also
counters
bad sinus problems if you have an immune
system issue so if you have really bad
sinuses chances are you could be
deficient in vitamin a but vitamin a
does a lot of other things as well then
we have a lack of vitamin e well that
could show up in your heart so maybe you
get more inflammation in the heart in
the coronary arteries which shows up as
calcification higher levels of
cholesterol plaquing
things like that other than that it
probably won't do anything else i'm
being very sarcastic
then we have vitamin d let's say you
can't absorb vitamin d
well that's a big problem because you
need it for
getting rid of pain you need it for
decreasing blood pressure you need it
for the formation of calcium in your
bones and as well as the absorption of
calcium in the small intestine so if you
don't have vitamin d
the rate of absorption of calcium is
like way way lower with vitamin d you
absorb 20 times as much calcium as if
you didn't have it so now you have all
sorts of calcium problems like bone loss
and
problem sleeping at night and you name
it then we have vitamin k with vitamin
k1 and vitamin k2 if you're deficient in
vitamin k1 then you get bruising easily
you bleed easily you can't clot as well
and with vitamin k2 a deficiency of that
you have a calcium building up in the
arteries as well as the joints
then we have other fats like omega-3
fatty acids you need that to keep your
inflammation really low and without
enough omega-3 fatty acids you have all
sorts of inflammatory conditions
arthritis
heart problems
even dementia because of the involvement
in your brain
your brain apparently needs a lot of
omega-3 fatty acids now the other thing
that
bile does is it helps get rid of the
excess amount of cholesterol let's say
for example you decide you're going to
lose weight and you get on the ketogenic
diet and now all this fat cell is
releasing its triglyceride
and its cholesterol that's what's in
a fat cell the combination of
triglycerides which is can be used for
energy
and also
cholesterol which can't be used as
energy so we need bile to help eliminate
that excess amount of cholesterol so if
you don't have enough bile
because you don't have enough capacity
of liver function
then you end up with
gallstones gallstones are created by a
super concentrated
cholesterol situation because there's
not enough bile to emulsify and break it
down so we get this crystallization of
cholesterol so when people have
gallstones they actually need more bile
they don't need necessarily less
cholesterol
and then you also have people that are
on statin drugs which basically block
the production of cholesterol and guess
what bile is made out of
cholesterol this is why the risk goes
way up
in getting gallstones and all these
other issues if someone's on a statin
and then the other big important purpose
of bile salts is to help eliminate
toxins
and now your body becomes instantly more
toxic because you don't you can't get
rid of the toxins that are floating to
the liver because the purpose of the
liver is not to store toxins it's to
break down toxins into harmless
particles so if you can't break them
down then and you're taking medication
and you're being exposed to planet earth
boy you get a lot of extra poisonous
things that are flooding through the
bloodstream and through your body so we
really need this liver to work correctly
another symptom of a fatty liver is that
you start getting a heavier liver it
becomes enlarged
and that pressure
doesn't fit in the cavity anymore on the
right side so it backs up and it puts
pressure into the right side of your
neck
up to here to the shoulder so you get
shoulder pain uh you get a lot of
tension in your right trap and that can
create a fullness underneath the right
rib cage is one of the symptoms
and you know people say well i need to
flush out my gallbladder well you know
you need to get rid of the fat in the
liver it's a little bit different than
fleshing out
anything which i'm going to explain the
other important part about the
liver is its conversion function from t4
to t3 your thyroid without a good liver
you can't convert the thyroid hormones
so you might have hormones there but
they're not activated because they can't
be converted 80 percent
of all the active form of t3 the thyroid
hormone
works through the liver so without that
liver fully functioning
maybe you get
70 or 60 or 50 of it being converted and
here you are wondering why do i have a
thyroid problem there's no reason to
have a thyroid problem the problem is
not the thyroid it's your liver it's the
conversions
okay
very important
the other very important function of the
liver is to
buffer um
certain excesses of sex hormones like
estrogen and testosterone it's not good
to have too much testosterone or too
much estrogen and so without the liver
working right you cannot form the
proteins to
buffer those hormones and so then we
have
issues like polycystic ovarian syndrome
in women which is
too much androgen and we also have too
much estrogen and even men they start
getting all sorts of problems with
breast tissue
and low testosterone and the list goes
on and on and on now because i talked a
bit more on bile i do want to mention
some other symptoms
to
try to identify if you have low bile
okay number one do you have an
intolerance to digesting fat when you
eat fat do you find that you get more
bloating that would be an indication
that you need more bile do you find that
your stool is light colored like pale or
even gray
or does it float
or does it leave skid marks
that could mean that you're low in bile
do you find that after you eat you're
just not satisfied
well maybe because you're not extracting
the fats
to be absorbed to then tell the brain
like okay i'm done eating that could be
a sign that you need more bile if you
have
nausea or you have indigestion or
bloating those can be signs bloating
burping belching
are classic signs of low bile as well
all right so now that you have some
basics
on the liver and the importance of bile
[Music]
bile is really important into keeping
the fat out of the liver so anything you
can do to increase bile reserves is
going to help you get rid of a fatty
liver so some people even take purified
bile salts and i did put a link down
below for more information on that but
today i want to talk about a
a really simple shake you can make too
to help reduce fat on your liver now i
just want to let you know that
being on the ketogenic diet as well as
doing intermittent fasting together
can
reduce
the fat on your liver by 50 in just 14
days
if you haven't seen that video i put
that down below so i just wanted to give
you that foundation first because it's
essential to go on keto and doing
intermittent fasting if you have a fatty
liver but this shake i'm going to talk
about next is a really simple thing
everyone can do to keep fat off your
liver and it's backed by some pretty
good science
so the ingredients are simple you're
going to use kale
you're going to use blueberries and
you're going to use kefir okay i would
use organic cal and organic blueberries
and i would keep them in the freezer
okay keep them in the freezer they're
much easier to blend so you just take
your blender out and you take two cups
of kale frozen and you can break it up
into little chunks just put two cups of
kale in there because it blends really
nicely when it's cold and it tastes
better too and then you put one cup of
blueberries blueberries not only have
curicin but so does kale kirsoten is the
ultimate weapon against the fatty liver
not to mention its involvement in many
other aspects of your health including
having a stronger immune system but
kercetin is a
is a fabulous vital nutrient to target a
fatty liver but there's many other
things in kale and blueberries that also
help you with fatty liver and liver
function in general so we take two cups
of frozen kale okay put in a blender we
take one cup of frozen blueberries okay
we put a cup of water and we also put
one cup of plain whole fat
kefir okay don't get the flavored kind
don't get the sweetened kind get the
organic if possible
grass-fed if possible whole milk plain
kefir that's going to give you the
probiotics that you need to reduce fat
on your liver so we have the water the
kefir the kale and the blueberries and
then you're going to simply blend this
up for a couple minutes okay and blend
it up really nicely and then chug it
down it tastes really good and it's
extremely effective in reducing fat on
your liver and do that every single day
in combination with a healthy keto diet
as well as intermittent fasting now if
you haven't seen my video on how to
reduce a fatty liver within 14 days
put it right here check it out
you